ganz herzlichen dank für diese
einleitenden worte ich freue mich hier
zu ihnen sprechen zu dürfen
ich freue mich auch besonders hier in
einem ort im programm zu ihnen sprechen
zu dürfen der sich gewissermaßen an
einer schnittstelle befindet wir haben
ja bisher über bäume überwiegend
zumindest über räume im traditionellen
topischen sinn gesprochen und stehen
jetzt davor die grenze zu überschreiten
wenn sie auf das weitere programm
vorausblicken zu einem ja wenn nicht
atopischen so doch eher utopischen
raumkonzept also virtuelle räume
vorgestellte räume zu betreten
die genau über diese grenze möchte ich
im folgenden nicht nur gehen sondern
auch sprechen
dabei sind die beiden bereiche diesseits
und jenseits der grenze
keineswegs voneinander so isoliert und
hermetisch abgeriegelt wie das die
grenzziehung suggeriert wir über formen
die der realität zugeordneten räume
ständig mit gedanklichen konstrukten und
unsere vorstellungen speisen wir
wiederum aus erfahrungen der realität
die idee eines gedanken palastes öffnet
sich dabei zu beiden bereichen hin
transportiert gewissermaßen pendler
zwischen ihnen hin und her und
unterläuft damit in besonderem maße die
grenze zwischen einem typischen und
utopischen raum
traditionell sind gedanken paläste meist
als mittel untersucht worden und
begriffe oder texte auswendig zu lernen
also als gedächtnis allahs seit
jahrtausenden beschreiben autoren die
praxis in gedanken räume zu entwerfen
dort informationen in materialisierte
form abzulegen und diese informationen
dann abzurufen indem man die
gedankengebäude beschreitet das ziel ist
dabei also informationen im gedächtnis
zu speichern
von diesem modell aus möchte ich mit
ihnen drei grenzübergänge an drei
verschiedenen zonen des gedanken
palastes erkunden und versuchen an
diesen grenzen dem herkömmlichen modell
eine moderne architektur zu verleihen
erstens bewegen wir uns zwischen
verschiedenen ebenen geschossen wenn sie
so wollen nach oben und unten
zweitens ergeben blicke nach vorne und
hinten verbindungslinien oder achsen
drittens verhalten sich innen und außen
interieur und exterieur unseres gedanken
palastes mit dem ersten punkt
gedankliche ebenen die sich übereinander
legen meine ich codierung schichten also
werden für einen gedanken palast für
eine gedächtnis palast vielmehr die zu
speichernden informationen mehrfach
codiert anleitungen und beschreibungen
gehen etwa davon aus dass eine wortliste
oder ein text zu memorieren ist
informationen also bereits verbalisiert
und damit auf einer ersten ebene
sprachlich kodiert sind
dieser sprach code wird anschließend ein
weiteres mal codiert indem er mit
bestimmten äußeren eigenschaften des
sprach codes in dem mit bestimmten
äußeren eigenschaften des sprach kurz
eine visuelle wahrnehmung assoziiert
wird in der regel handelt es sich dann
um akzidenz ii alle eigenschaften diese
sprachkurs etwa das schriftbild eine
mehrdeutigkeit oder assoziationen in
bezug auf die aussprache bei giordano
bruno etwa finden wir die technik ein zu
memorieren das wort erst in seine
buchstaben zu zerlegen dann mit jedem
buchstaben einen namen zu verbinden der
mit dem buchstaben beginnt und sich dann
eine gruppe berühmter personen
vorzustellen deren die den jeweiligen
namen die die jeweiligen namen tragen da
haben wir jetzt also mit insgesamt drei
codierung schichten zu tun
in ähnlicher weise kann man etwa das
schrift
zu einem sinnbild transformieren dass es
als schlange oder wörter werden in
einigermaßen alberne geschichten
eingebaut die man dann vor dem inneren
auge ab rufen soll touristen erinnern
sich etwa an das geschehen einer
hochzeitsnacht um sich zu
vergegenwärtigen auf welchen arten über
ein recht verfügt werden kann
der reiz einer solchen codierung markt
darin bestehen eine lebhafte erinnerung
durch ungewöhnliche verbindungen oder
sogar obszöne anklänge zu fördern
ähnlich wie bei eselsbrücken und dieser
weg mag bei der speicherung einzelner
informationseinheiten noch praktikabel
sein sobald es jedoch um größere
strukturen und gedankliche zusammenhänge
geht die in räumliche formen übersetzt
werden sollen stehen solche zusätzlichen
codierung schichten nur im weg wie
können wir sie daher aufbrechen und wenn
nicht eliminieren so doch zumindest an
auf ein minimum mit hoher
durchsichtigkeit reduzieren wir können
uns zunächst von einer negativen seite
nähern außen vor bleiben sollte da die
sprachliche ebene
zumal sie selbst häufig schon mehrere
ebenen beinhaltet in dem die sprache
abstrakte vorgänger mit konkreten
wahrnehmungen bis zur abnutzung zur
katechese hin verknüpft verweist sie
selbst auf notwendigerweise räumliche
vorstellungsbild man kann somit die
sprachliche ebene auch überspringen und
sich sogleich auf eine visuelle ebene
begeben
hinzu kommen das ist heutzutage anders
als vielleicht noch vor erfindung des
buchdrucks weniger darauf ankommt
wörtliche texte zu memorieren weiterhin
aus einer negativen perspektive sollte
eine verheimlichung spontanen
assoziationen mit vorsicht begegnen
jede information die wir wahrnehmen
insbesondere jedem text projizieren wir
unwillkürlich
ich und meist auch unmerklich in einem
konstruierten räumlichen kontext gerade
das recht projiziert eine ganze
parallelwelt da es sich in deinem
normativen charakter des sollens steht
gegen eine vorgegebene realität des
seins wendet gedanklicher wie räumlicher
kontext sind jedoch in hohem grade
variabel und manipulierbar
so nehmen wir zum beispiel nur aufgrund
unseres räumlichen kontext konstrukts
noch er an dass menschen gegen jede
physiognomische erfahrung verzerrt sind
als dass der raum verteilt ist in dem
sie sich befinden und anderes beispiel
akzeptieren physikalisch unmögliche er
als die tatsache dass wir den
perspektivischen kontext falsch gewählt
haben einen gedanken palast kann den
gegenüber den kontext von informationen
bewusst konstruieren und so auch eine
spätere kontextualisierung erleichtern
was damit also positiv bleibt ist das
ziel
abstrakte konzepte so in eine räumliche
vorstellungswelt zu übersetzen dass ihr
räumlicher repräsentant möglichst
dieselben eigenschaften und dieselben
beziehungen zu anderen elementen
aufweist
idealerweise nimmt dann der nutzer bei
einer derart eingängigen und stimmigen
codierung gar nicht mehr den inhalt als
code war den er erst entschlüsseln muss
sondern er fast intuitiv mit einem blick
die relevanten merkmale die sprachlich
viel mühsamer erst zu ver und dann zu
entschlüsseln wären um dann dabei noch
möglichst viele optionen zu haben sollte
man die visualisierung aus einem
möglichst großen repertoire schöpfen
baumann farben aber auch andere als
visuelle etwa akustische olfaktorische
eindrücke verarbeiten die sich dann noch
in einer zeitlichen dimension
dynamisieren lassen
ein einfaches beispiel aus der
juridischen anwendung ist etwa dieses
bild hier an dem man die bedingtheit von
leistung und gegenleistung also
juristisch den automatischen wegfall der
gegen leistungspflicht bei wegfall einer
leistungspflicht ohne große umschweife
erklärt haben einer loslässt fällt der
andere auch oder etwa die visualisierung
von rechtsakten als spielkarten und
spielzüge die sich eine fülle komplexer
strukturen integrieren lässt der zweite
punkt als zweiten punkt und auch ihnen
zeigen diese beispiele eigentlich schon
ganz gut geht es um die art der zu
speichernden informationen oder
vielleicht eher noch um die frage ob
informationsspeicherung überhaupt der
richtige ansatz ist der traditionelle
gedächtnis palast suggeriert dass es
abgeschlossene informationseinheiten
gibt die wir in säuberlich ab
geschnürten paketen separat deponieren
können diese abstrahierende vorstellung
verdeckt jedoch dass informationen im
grunde nichts anderes sind als
beziehungen beziehungen zum empfänger
der information aber auch beziehungen
zwischen solchen beziehungen ohne in ein
ganzes gewebe an beziehungen eingebettet
zu sein sind informationen daher sinnlos
das heißt es können keine weiteren
operationen an sie angeknüpft werden
je weiter dieses gewebe reicht ihr mehr
informationen es miteinander verknüpft
je besser es den gespeicherten wissen
eine struktur verleiht desto ergiebiger
können wir damit arbeiten wollen wir
einen gedanken palast in diese richtung
nutzbar machen müssen wir also räumliche
verknüpfungen herstellen
offene stadt geschlossenen raum konzepte
entwickeln
sichtachsen eröffnen den blick also um
uns herum nach vorne und hinten
erweitern
im gemeinsamen gestaltungselementen
können
dann ähnlichkeit beziehungen sichtbar
werden oder etwa in einem
gestalterischen entflechtung einzelne
ineinander verflochtene gedanken gerade
in der begriffswelt juristische
entscheidungen lagern oft mehrere
schichten an begründung mustern
übereinander deren trennung sprach und
seit der trennung und deren
zusammenhänge sprachlich oft nur sehr
mühsam darzustellen ist räumlich dagegen
können wir wie in diesem beispiel hier
das ziel dass eine person mit
rechtlichen mitteln einfordert als
endprodukt als als endpunkt eines weges
darstellen alternative wege dorthin
ausmachen und dann gegeneinander abwägen
und etwa gegen interessen die in die
gegenrichtung ziehen
dieses gesamte szenario lässt sich
sodann noch aus verschiedenen
perspektiven betrachten etwa aus einem
fenster aus dem wir dann nur einen
ausschnitt sehen können
den ausschnitt zum beispiel für den wir
als gericht zuständig sind für denen wir
verwertbare beweise haben zu dem es noch
keine andere entscheidung gibt die
unsere entscheidung blockiert was
außerdem für einen rechtlichen prüfer
dann zu weit entfernt ist das und schwer
zu untersuchen ist das kann dann außer
betracht bleiben aus effizienzgründen
untrennbar mit ihrem gedanken inhalt
verwoben ist aber auch der denkprozess
der zu diesem inhalt führt die abfolge
von gedanklichen schritten die wir gehen
müssen um etwa ein bestimmtes problem zu
lösen
auch diese prozedurale seite kann ein
gedanken räumliches setting
strukturieren und dadurch eine routine
im wörtlichen sinn einer kleinen route
etablieren die die lösungen von
gedanklichen aufgaben erleichtert
juristische klausuren zum beispiel
bestehen immer aus sehr viel text den
man gedanklich in sektoren aufteilen
kann dann diese sektoren neu sortieren
kann um daraus die lösung zu bauen
musiker und sportler können körper
die abläufe mental trainieren zum
beispiel auf einer gedanklichen
klaviatur spielen oder räumliche
vorstellungen nutzen um ihre darbietung
zu beeinflussen wir haben ja heute auch
schon von gedanken experimenten in den
naturwissenschaften gehört oder von
mentalen operation zellen in der medizin
schließlich liefert der räumliche
gesamtzusammenhang einen gesamteindruck
der sich zwar nicht in einem in einem
konkreten inhalt niederschlägt aber doch
den psychischen grundzustand berührt die
räumliche umgebung hat einfluss auf
unser wohlbefinden damit auf unsere
mentale leistungsfähigkeit und unsere
konzentrations reserven sich gedanklich
in eine vertraute und stimulierende
umgebung zu versetzen hat daher das
potenzial positive wirkungen auszulösen
zb äußere ablenkungen auszublenden sich
von geistige anstrengungen zu erholen
oder sogar prüfungsangst abzumildern
der dritte punkt innen und außen grenze
führt uns an eine weitere grenze die
jeder raum konstituiert innen und außen
unter alltags blick trend einen raum
stets von seinem inhalt einen palast von
seinem inventar eine hülle also von
ihrer erfüllung
diese trennung erleichtert es zwar die
architektur eines gedanken palastes zu
entwerfen da sie ohne rücksicht auf
seine spätere inneneinrichtung gestaltet
werden kann und deshalb beispielsweise
auch reale vorlage genutzt werden können
bei genauerem hinsehen engt die innen
außengrenze aber von der perspektive des
betrachters ab oder sogar von letztlich
jedem beliebigen bezugspunkt wobei wir
uns dann im alltag lediglich mit
konvention alliierten bezugspunkten
behelfen innen und außen hülle und
inhalt verhalten sich damit dergestalt
dass jeder
inhalt hülle und jede hülle zugleich
inhalt sein kann
deshalb sind auch arterie und exterieur
und eines gedanken palastes letztlich
nicht voneinander zu trennen bedingen
sich vielmehr gegenseitig wirken
aufeinander ein
jeder inhalt stellt anforderungen an
seinen räumlichen kontext und umgekehrt
lässt sich in eine bestimmte räumliche
struktur nicht jeder beliebige inhalt
einpassen
diese dichotomie zwischen innen und
außen verschließt auch dimensional
zwischen der unendlichen weiten des
weltraums und der unendlichen engel der
atom welt so können wir einen gedanken
palast ausbauen zu gedanklichen gärten
in amtlichen straßen bis hin zu städten
gebirgen oder mehreren ohne innen und
außen zu unterscheiden
mit diesem potenzial an vorhandene
strukturen in alle richtungen immer
weiter anbauen zu können entspricht der
gedanken palast der offenheit
postmoderner verstehens prozesse eine
gedankliche kartographie die keine
endgültige orientierung bietet sondern
fortwährend neues verortet und altes
überschreibt wird zugleich dem heutigen
bild unserer hirnstruktur gerecht
beispiel für eine solche fluide anlage
des gedanken palastes ist der entwurf
eines stadtplans oder hier eines u bahn
plans bei dem jede station einen
straftatbestand des deutschen
strafrechts markiert durch den dann die
linien verschiedene davon geschützter
interessen führen diesen linien kann man
dann in verschiedene lebensweltliche
bezirke vordringen straßenverkehr
geschäftsverkehr familien sphäre und die
traummaße der einzelnen stationen können
wiederum geprägt sein von parametern die
die strafbarkeit bestimmen etwa die von
der die strafbarkeit abhängt etwa die
höhe der strafe
die intensität einer verletzung der grad
ihrer verwirrt
entrücken wir unseren ausblick noch
weiter kehren wir wieder zu der grenze
zurück die uns eingangs begegnet ist
der gedanken palast selbst als innenwelt
zur außenwelt des alltags wie können wir
nun diese grenze überwinden wie können
wir den gedanken palast also mit dem
universitären lehre und lernen alltag
verbinden einen gedanken palast setzt
voraus dass wir unsere lernumgebung ganz
bewusst gestalten
in johann rowlings roman welt gibt es in
der zauberschule hogwarts einen raum der
wünsche der sich den bedürfnissen seiner
jeweiligen nutzer anpasst im englischen
ist das noch deutlicher der room of
requirements
nach diesem prinzip sollte eine
lernumgebung möglichst flexibel
gestaltbar und frei von ablenkungen sein
um sie dann selbst tatsächlich oder
gedanklich ausfüllen zu können
denn jeder gegenstand jedes verhältnis
von gegenständen zueinander kommuniziert
bereits eine stimmung eine erwartung
oder sogar konkrete inhalte ja also ein
gerichtssaal etwa bringt als
zeremonielle kulisse ein ganz bestimmtes
formalisiertes verfahren mit
unpersönlichen über individuellen rollen
zum ausdruck und sperrt alles aus was
nicht hinein getragen wird
wenn man das spielfeld des gerichtssaals
betritt akzeptiert man auch in gewissem
maße bereits seine spielregeln und
legitimiert damit die resultierende
entscheidung unabhängig vom eigenen
standpunkt dagegen baut jeder gedanken
palast auf individuellen vorstellungen
und es einzigartig sein architekt und
bewohner kann außenstehende nicht
autoritär hindurch führen sondern nur
dazu anregen einen eigenen gedanken
palast zu bauen und zu erkunden
abwechslungsreiche oder technologisch
neuartige sinneseindrücke können
die neugier stimulieren selbst
gedankliche pfade anzulegen
in diesem sinne dient bereits das bild
eines palastes nicht etwa das eines
gedanken raumes zimmers oder einfach
gebäudes allein dazu eine ästhetische
faszination zu wecken
in ähnlicher offenheit haben schon
antike philosophenschule niere dann auch
namensgebenden wirkungsstätten zu einer
gedanklichen plattform zementiert die
akademie den perry partners die store
den caps weder die impulse dazu noch
einen gedanken palast selbst dürfen
unnötig komplex oder überfrachtet sein
im gegenteil besteht seine funktion
gerade darin zu vereinfachen
ein erlebnis kognitiver leichtigkeit
hervorzurufen
das regelmäßig geht durchschreiten
letztlich zu automatisieren
so ist es denn auch das architektonische
ideal
unsere drei grenzübergänge zu
überbrücken
also codierung schichten übereinander
informations beziehungen nebeneinander
und hülle und inhalt ineinander darauf
ausgerichtet komplexität zu reduzieren
ansonsten kippt einen gedanken palast
zum gedanken ballast vielen dank